design is subjective
there's just no way of getting around
that fact and
architecture in a lot of ways is the art
of
convincing people that your design moves
were the right moves
and one of the ways you can convince
people is through case studies
i think of case studies like a shield if
you present it correctly
it can be a very powerful way for you to
defend your design moves
especially if you're choosing a project
that's been successful before
and it's been done by a well-known
architect it can build a very solid
foundation
for you to build your design strategies
from
and it can be a lot harder to poke holes
at something that's been
proven to be successful before there is
a lot of information out there on how to
do case studies
but not so much on how to present them
so if you're looking for information on
how to do them this is not the video for
you
in this video i'm gonna show you how to
present them in a way that's
informative in a way that's engaging
and in a way that can create a
bulletproof defense for your project
hey guys how's it going my name is dani
and i'm an architect
based in vancouver on this channel i
make videos about architecture design
and creativity
one of the reasons i started this
youtube channel is because i miss the
presentation and storytelling aspect of
architecture school
and so this is a process that i love
and it's a process that i'm always
trying to refine
but this is a fun topic for me so when i
started architecture school
i was absolutely terrible at
presentations i would get stage fright
i would get nervous i would shake i
could hear my heartbeat
and of course i would work right up to
the presentation
i would have pulled like two
all-nighters before
i would basically wing it every single
time
so as you can imagine they did not go
very well
it wasn't well into my second year of
architecture school that i
sort of started to get the hang of it i
think it was a combination
of like actually liking my project and
being proud of them and wanting to
tell a story that kind of did it justice
and also getting a little bit better at
time management so that i could
plan out my presentations beforehand so
slowly and slowly i
started to improve but it was actually
in my
thesis year when i really started to
strategize on my presentation technique
and sort of build a system around it so
this is a strategy that i've refined
over
years and years of presenting my own
work and
from observing other people present
nobody actually taught me this
so it is a little bit different from the
standard way of presenting your case
studies
but throughout my bachelor's and my
master's i did receive
numerous awards for my project and for
my thesis
i received the aia henry adams award
which is
the highest honor you can get for your
thesis project in north america
and i attribute this a lot to my
presentation methods
just before we start let's just cover
the basics what are
case studies case studies are when you
study an existing building
or an existing project usually a
well-known piece of architecture
to inform your design if you want to
design a chicken coop
you don't really want to start from
scratch you want to see how
other people have done it you want to
see how other people
located their chicken coops how they
shaped it
how they place the doors and you want to
learn from their mistakes
and you want to use that to inform your
design a lot of times students present
case studies
as a formality because it's a
requirement but that is such a
missed opportunity you are using your
precious minutes of your presentation
time
to talk about someone else's building so
you want to
use that to prepare the viewers for what
they're about to see
with your design so how do you present
case studies so i like to call the
strategy
sam simplify and multiply
so first simplify so presenting
a case study is very different from
doing a case study when you're doing a
case study
you might learn a lot of different
things from it but when you're
presenting it
you just want to show the aspect that
you're going to be employing in your
design
and then you want to diagram graphics
and visual continuity is key
you want to take the plan elevation in
section and you want to diagram on top
of it
and multiply instead of just
studying one or two buildings do
multiple
so i read an article a long time ago
about why architectural research is so
slow to progress compared to other
disciplines like
science or medicine and apparently
it's because we usually tend to
create a unique one-off solution
to the design as opposed to
collecting a massive sample of
architecture
and creating statistics i mean this is
the fundamental tool behind scientific
research
like they take a massive sample and then
they make some assumptions based on that
and so we want to do the same thing we
want to study a bunch of different
buildings
and we want to show hey look like
all of these different buildings achieve
the thing that i want to achieve
by doing it this way and you want to
show that you have that understanding
especially if you want to deviate from
that and come up with your
unique solution i mean if you just show
one or two case studies
no matter how successful that project is
it's not really a good defense for your
case
because you know those buildings could
have had really unique conditions
like they could have had a really unique
site or a program right
so it's not really a good basis
to build your design off of and just one
more thing before we jump into the
example
um the common advice is to study
a building that has the same function as
the function that you want to do
in your project but in my
humble opinion that is not always
necessary
because most architecture is a unique
response to a site or program
and you want to create your unique
response so i wouldn't really base it on
the function or the program
but i would base it on the feeling
or the atmosphere or the way you want
people to behave
in that particular space and i would try
to emulate those
in your design i'll kind of show you
what i mean in a sec
just a little background my thesis
project was called a library
of the mind explorations on slow reading
browsing and serendipity and i was
looking at our culture of speed and
productivity
and how that has affected our culture of
learning this
has also had a pretty big impact in our
building typologies in our libraries
where we went from
quiet reading rooms to large
collaborative working spaces
and so the physical thing that i created
was a library in venice
and through the project it was a
discourse on all these different aspects
like learning
innovation serendipity so this is the
first page of the case study page
and as you can see i'm not showing the
buildings as a main focus of the page
the title of this page is visual harmony
and moment of pause so you can see here
i've given
three examples of buildings that have
achieved visual harmony
through the use of proportions so as you
go through these projects you can give a
little spiel
about the significance of each project
but the idea is that the visuals it
speaks for itself
and um it's very easy
to convey these architectural elements
without
you having to say a bunch of things
about it so just be strategic
based on how much time you're given for
the presentation
if you're only given 15 minutes you kind
of
want to breeze through this if you have
like half an hour
then you can go a little bit more in
depth into each building
and in most cases the case studies that
you'll be doing
are buildings that like your peers
and your professors will know about um
because you are speaking to an
architectural audience
um so like you shouldn't have to
go too much in depth in describing like
the
particular significance of each building
you just want to
distill the qualities of that space that
you're taking into your design
the second one is rhythm and movement
which is important
in slowing us down psychologically and
physically before we enter
our reading space and so i'm
showing how these two examples
are doing that the first one through a
series of arcades
and then in exeter library through a
series of colonnades
and the third one is about nestling
which is um
all about the architecture itself
creating an enclosure
around your body so that you can sit
comfortably and
read your books and then the next one is
narrative sequence which is creating
special
memorable moments in the space through
distinct
architectural elements and then we have
degrees of privacy
slash intimacy
and i'm showing how these three
buildings
uh have created a buffer
between the outside world and
this intimate space of reading both
physically and
psychologically and then the last one is
the design of the stacks
and browsing which i talk about as an
important feature
in creating serendipitous discoveries
and then once you go into showing your
project
you can use the same graphics into your
building so
i'll show you an example here so this is
the pathway
approaching my building so this
labyrinthian pathway
and you get into this narrow low dark
corridor
and bam you come into this open
grand courtyard and you see here i'm
using the same graphics
i was using in my case study and if you
want to reinforce it a little bit more
on the next page you can show
the visuals that you were showing in
your case study on the sides
i typically try to create visual
continuity so i'll have the same
graphics here
and here but i'll just change the color
of the background
just so that like i'm switching back and
forth between my design
and the explanation of my design and you
really have to do this for like
a split second throughout your
presentation just so that
your audience understands okay like i
understand
where that architectural element is
coming from
and then again back to your building
you circulate around the courtyard
through a series of
rhythmic colonnades to slow us down
psychologically and physically before we
get into
the library and then the next page i
have the same
graphics as i had in the case studies
and then on the next page i'll show a
render and i'll just
keep doing this throughout the
presentation
and so as you go through your
presentation you're reinforcing the
reason
why you made certain design moves and at
the end of your presentation
um you can really focus on
um discussing your ideas not like
oh why did you do this like why didn't
you do this
and hopefully it opens up the room for
um a more open discussion rather than
like
a critique on your design and if it is
more of a direct critique then you
are able to speak more intelligibly
about your design moves
um which is really the point you want to
get to
so i hope you guys found this helpful um
and if you have any questions just let
me know
if you enjoy this video i think you will
also enjoy one of my other videos
where i do a quick architectural design
process
from beginning to the end and
in that video you can also see me
attempt to do
a headstand
[Music]
aah
you